hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday power struggles between number 10
and number 11 are nothing new but when
you have a new Chancellor openly
criticizing the mistakes made by the
Prime Minister expected to junk Central
parts of her budget and pledging to do
things very differently now he's in the
job you do have to ask yourself where
does power really lie particularly
because right now it's easier to see Liz
trust losing her job than Jeremy Hunt
losing his on the show today we'll be
asking is triconomics dead and what does
that mean for the future of the Prime
Minister we'll try to find out with our
guests we're joined today by both a
Chancellor and the chief Secretary of
the Treasury left the treasury on Friday
but City Minister Andrew Griffiths
remains he'll be on the show part of
Quasi quantum's original team we'll also
be talking to the senior conservative
back bencher Robert Halton chair of the
education committee likely to be looking
carefully at the Chancellor's warning of
difficult decisions on government
spending ahead
the labor will talk to the shadow
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds
and with that new squeeze on public
spending there's renewed fears of wise
dread strikes ahead we're talking to the
unite General Secretary Sharon Graham
Market turmoil and economic uncertainty
has haunted the new government and may
yet bring down the Prime Minister we'll
talk to The Economist to Charlie beam
formerly of the office for Budget
responsibility and Bank of England
[Music]
hello good morning well even by the
standards of the last few years the
turmoil at the very top of government
over the past few days has been
extraordinary the Sunday papers today
are full of speculation about who could
replace Liz trust as five weeks into the
job well our next guest is someone who
has always championed the conservatism
of blue collar workers according to
reports this week he told Liz truss that
she's trashed 10 years at the
conservative's record on looking after
those workers well we can talk now to
Robert Half and who is the MP for Harlow
and chair of the education committee
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning
you've written an article in the times
this week saying that the new government
is blowing up the conservative party and
the country I mean I think many would
look at the events the last few weeks
and agree with you but can you just
explain what you mean by that
well I worry that over the past few
weeks the government has looked like a
Libertarian jihadists and and treated
the whole country as a kind of
laboratory mice in which to carry out
kind of ultra Ultra free market
experiments and this is not where the
where the country is there's been one
Horror Story a story after another it's
not just about tax cuts for the rich but
about benefit Cuts cuts to Public
Services even today we're reading that
they may impose charges on long-term
sick and disabled for uh who are parking
at hospitals and this is not what the
what the public wants and I really
believe that the Prime Minister given
everything that has gone on needs to set
out do I do a fireside chat to the
British people apologize for what has
gone on and set out a vision for
compassionate conservatism with social
justice at its heart
so you think the Prime Minister needs to
apologize personally
do you know um yesterday in my
constituency one person after another
expressed a dismay but
um one or two people actually said to me
that they were frightened
frightened about everything that had
gone on worried about their payments
worried about their mortgages worried
about their a small small business and I
don't want a government where where
people come up to me in the street and
saying they're frightened about this
isn't about the opinion polls this is
about we're in danger of creating a
after the covert pandemic an economic
pandemic unless things aren't sorted out
uh really really soon we you know the
country wants affordable housing they
need a public spending to be maintained
on essential services like my area of
education for example they want tax cuts
but focused on the lower paid and those
who are struggling the most the the
government should recast the energy
package which whilst I welcomed it of
course it was a huge intervention it
should be focused predominantly on the
poor and those who are wealthy and big
business should not be getting uh
rebates as currently set out
um you're obviously someone who's always
you know as we said in the introduction
you know championed the values of
blue-collar workers you know not the
super rich people who work hard to earn
you know a moderate salary people like
places like Harley where you represent
do they think
Mr is on their side or do you think what
has happened is effectively playing into
people's concerns that the conservatives
always just look after the rich
well the awful stereotypes of
conservatives in the past that we were
just the party for the well-off and the
rich the government over the past few
weeks have played into that uh
stereotype every day of the week and as
I say said to you the biggest problem
for me is not that my constituents are
angry at the government but some of them
are actually frightened because they
fear for what has has gone on and this
can't can't continue you know I welcome
what uh Jeremy Hunt was saying uh
yesterday in the media
um but the proof of the pudding will be
in the me in the eating they have to be
dramatic improvements and pretty quickly
you say you welcome some of what the new
Chancellor said but Jeremy Hunt also
said that spending needs to be looked at
efficiencies need to be found now you
are someone who's always talked about
the values of Public Services
particularly of course in education
where you have a a particular interest
are you concerned that we might be
seeing a return to austerity
well to be fair when we had austerity
under George was born and uh David
Cameron they managed to protect some of
the core budgets they cut taxes for
lower earners they introduce the living
wage they created millions of
apprenticeships they reformed our
welfare they were able to do all this
even though there was austerity because
they got the deficit under control so it
can be done of course they have to be
efficiencies but we absolutely cannot
cut public services in the core areas I
mean just to look at education over
between 2010 and 2025 it will only have
had a three percent increase in real in
real terms our kids have suffered
massively because of school closures
during lockdown there has to be more
investment in education and if the
government is saying they can increase
defense spending they can hardly say
well no we haven't got any money for a
essential services is like funding our
schools and colleges properly
now we're talking about the new
Chancellor here there are reports in the
papers this morning that number 10
originally approached Sergey Javit to
see if he would be interested in being
Chancellor now he's one of your closest
allies in the House of Commons you went
to University together your friends
there you helped run his leadership
campaign is it true that he was sounded
out for that job
I have no idea I'm not going to party to
those discussions they're way above my
pay grade but I'm just made to read in
the newspapers the briefings that have
come out using four-letter words to
describe Sajid Javid I've known him as
you say since University is a really
good man he was respected he didn't tank
the economy when he was a Chancellor and
if the Prime Minister wants to unite the
party and get people around her then
these kind of negative briefings about
colleagues have got to have got to stop
I just want to read the quote that you
allude to there just so people know what
we're talking about I am going to edit
my language because it is Sunday morning
this is a Sunday Times quote from a
number 10 Source
um when it was put to the Prime Minister
that she'd sounded outside a jabard the
Prime Minister laughed out loud at the
suggestion she sat in the cabinet with
jabard for 10 years and she knows who is
good and who is
the four letter word that you're
referring to is that briefing helpful
it's disgusting Javid is a respected and
good and decent man he's had a number of
offices a secretary of state and just to
call colleagues four letter words all it
does is uh bring this harmony to the
party when what the Prime Minister
should be doing is doing everything
possible to bring people together bring
the country uh country together it's
just absolutely unnecessary and uncalled
for
or do you think it sounds about the
current number 10 operation
well if they're doing things like this
and given the events of the last few
weeks clearly there have to be have to
be changes
um but it you know at the end of the day
this is about the government you you
they've uh they've got rid of one uh
Chancellor
um the the Prime Minister needs to
absolutely as I say say sorry to the
British people set out a vision of
compassionate conservatism support
workers conservatism as every prime
minister has done since 2010 including
Boris Johnson when he launched the
leveling up uh program and unify unify
the party
now I want to ask this question
um because you in some ways are at the
sharp end what the appalling polls the
concept of the party really mean you
know you represent Harlow uh it's always
been a bit of a Bellwether seat you took
it in 2010 you've been kind of
consolidating uh conservative support in
that seat ever since you know if you
look at the current polls it's game over
for the conservatives and places like
Harlow isn't it
well and you look at all the polling
done by Matthew Goodwin who's you know
not from the left very respected has
been advising Tori Prime Ministers and
toy senior toy party members for a long
time he's shown that in the so-called
red wall seats and working class seats
like mine in Harlow that we are
hemorrhaging in the in the polls and
that's what I was trying to say to the
Prime Minister the public want a
compassionate conservative government
they're not asking for libertarianism
they want fairness they want us spending
on essential Public Services they all do
want sell money as well and I mentioned
that during the Cameron years the
government were able to do to actually
do both and that's why things need to
change and pretty quickly
do things need to change at the top do
you think let's try should lead the
conservatives into the next election
well at this time I'm not calling for
the prime minister to go I worry about
further political instability but even
more economic instability but things
have to improve I I think she needs to
set out some of the things that I've
been suggesting the government as a
whole need to show that they are a
compassionate conservative government
because if things don't uh change then
maybe you know see I just think that
perhaps things may not be able to carry
on in the way that they have been I mean
there's talk in the papers about MPS
looking to install a Unity candidate to
replace her which is soon act Ben
Wallace Penny Morden all names mentioned
those conversations seriously happening
well of course
um colleagues are are unhappy with what
is going on we've hemorrhaged in the
opinion polls uh the public just can't
understand what has happened
um you know as I said many of them are
frightened about their their Futures and
their costs of of living it's inevitable
that colleagues are just uh we're all
talking to see what can be what can be
done about it and that's why I hope very
much in the next few days the government
has a dramatic reset apologizes for what
has gone on and and becomes the
concerted compassionate government that
the public voted for in 2019 and
implements the conservative Manifesto
that the public voted for in 2019.
you're talking there about the next few
days I mean is that the kind of time
frame that we're really talking about
for the prime minister to do something
differently and turn things around in
your view
it's got to be a dramatic change and
pretty quickly and to stabilize the
economy to reassure the uh the public
and to reset the government
thank you very much indeed always very
interesting to talk Robert Half on their
chair of the education at select
committee at consult of MP for Harlow
I think that's certainly it gives a bit
of a picture about some of the concerns
uh still on the conservative Ventures
and also the challenges ahead of course
for the new prime minister and the
chancellor to get that part of unity
that is so needed well Jeremy Hunt the
new Chancellor says that there will be
difficult decisions ahead on government
spending as we've just been discussing
it could of course mean less money for
Frontline Services potentially a squeeze
on pay and that could lead to yet more
action by the unions well let's go now
to Annex guest uh shall we are pleased
to say that we're joined by the General
Secretary of unite who is Sharon Graham
and joins us now thank you so much for
being with us
um we obviously need to start talking
about some of the events that have
unfolded over the last week we've got a
new Chancellor what are you hoping to
see from him well look I think that we
are witnessing a horror story to be
honest it's like watching a film behind
your hands and every time you look
there's something worse happening and I
think that we've got a real problem on
our hands Jeremy Hunt is not the answer
to what is happening here uh Jeremy Hunt
if you heard him yesterday was talking
about a second round of austerity and I
think what people will not put up with
after the 2008 financial crash this
country went through 10 years of
austerity 10 years of pain 10 years of
struggle workers and their families and
they did that because of the financial
crash we have another incident that is
not the fault of workers it's not the
fault of communities yet they will be
asked to pay the price so I think we've
got a real situation on our hands and we
really have to discuss now as a country
who is this economy for who is the
economy for and I think that there needs
to be a change in government
um do we also not need to discuss what
on Earth can anyone whoever the
government is do to try and regain the
trust of the markets and to look at what
many people are predicting I think in
the papers today 72 billion pound black
hole in the public finances Jeremy Hunt
are talking about looking at spending uh
as a yes but also looking at tax Rises
isn't that just being realistic no
because it's choices and that's what I
think really people are beginning to
understand now this is all about choices
not about one woman who's put her foot
on the accelerator because I think what
we've just seen is a glimpse of our
future nobody has said they think her
direction of travel is wrong what
they've said is the way that she's done
it is wrong and that looks to be where
they want to take us but these are
choices that you make how can you have a
situation where you make a choice to
make sure that Bankers do not have the
caps on their bonus that's a choice that
we've made but nurses can't get a pay
rise so we need an entire look at the
economy as a whole we need to say who is
this economy for who is it working for
trickle down does not work we can see
that it doesn't work who is it working
for and we do now need a change of
government
um you say that we need a change of
government and Liz truss has such a
chance learned she's u-turned on most of
the flagship policies in her budget
she's got a new Chancellor in place with
a very different economic strategy from
the last one do you think she can stay
in her job well I think she will because
she'll try to cling on she either will
or they'll try and replace her turkeys
aren't going to vote for Chris so whilst
I think that there should be a change in
government I have to say I don't think
that there will be a change in
government and probably they'll be
Clinging On right to the very end and
that is why labor have a real
opportunity now and they need to take
that opportunity and there's clear blue
water opened up on the political Horizon
there's no doubt about that but this is
not a moment to play it safe this is not
a moment to say um okay well look
they're doing so badly we just have to
sit on the sidelines here this is the
moment to take uh this by the Scruff of
the neck to say this is what we need to
do to come out with a solutions to these
problems and to really lay out what
labor stall is get some metal lay out
your stall and say what people should
vote for not just what they should vote
against because I guess if you look at
labor now the policies aren't that
different from the conservatives and
they're actually if you have grew the
papers actually saying the tax cuts
should go further than the conservatives
by the 1p cut to tax being brought in
before the list trust plan that you know
they agree with canceling their eyes in
National Insurance and they what is the
actual difference between labor and the
conservatives well there is a difference
because of course obviously what labor
will do is not attack workers in the
same way they'll do different things but
um I don't think it is acceptable just
to sit on the sidelines and have just a
little bit of difference is you can't
get in just because you're a little bit
better than the other lot what's about
is it the way what specifically would
you like to see labor do now then well
I'd like labor to really come out
fighting really to say look we are on
the side of workers and communities and
what does that mean so for example
asking the country to take a national
pay cut there is already a party for the
business Lobby it's called the Tory
party they they are the business Lobby
party and what we now need is to see the
party for workers and communities and
they come out very strongly and say look
we are the party for workers and
communities and this is what we would do
so for example a very simple thing is to
give the public sector workers their pay
rise that's a very simple thing that I
mean the thing about the economy Sophie
is there are choices and so the Banker's
choice is a choice to give Bankers their
bonuses back that are unfettered and
then to say to nurses you need to pay a
pay cut there are choices that are made
in the economy we want labor to come out
and make those choices more starkly so
people people can see them and have
something to vote for as well as
something to vote against because that's
really important do you think kirst
armor his character he's quite safety
first I guess do you think he's been a
bit too timid why do you want to talk
about personalities because obviously
let's hope we move a bit away from
personality politics it's the policies
that are the policy is too timid the
policy is too timid and we need you know
what people need now is straight talking
they don't want people dancing around
their handbags they want straight
talking this is the situation we are in
um I think everyone has seen the
direction of travel of where the
conservative party are taking us because
whilst as I said they are moving in that
direction they're saying too fast
they're not saying the Direction's wrong
they're saying the Direction's correct
where that Direction takes us uh Jeremy
Hunt yesterday was filled with Dread
when I heard him yesterday say you know
that we have to tighten our belts to say
that people have to be prepared for
tough decisions to be made that is code
for workers and communities will suffer
that is what that's code for remember
Jeremy Hunt was the health secretary who
effectively has a long history uh in in
this regard and so that's what that's
code for and you've had run-ins your
unions have run into a Jeremy hunter in
the past yeah during the junior doctors
strike and unite accused a man of
contemptuous Behavior well look what I
think is is Jeremy Hunt actually when he
was a health secretary one of the core
things that he did was that he wanted
the NHS to be part of the American trade
deal he wanted the NHS to be in the
American trade deal now I don't know
what his plans are for this country as
Chancellor but anything towards
privatizing the NHS or anything that is
going to make poor people poorer that
really is a difficulty I mean we've had
no indication that this government is
going to look into things like that and
but when it comes to um obviously
something that you're talking about an
awful lot is workers pay and where do
you think he will be on public set to
pay well I think he's already come out I
think I think one thing that will unite
the conservative party very quickly is
anti-trade Union legislation I think
they are saying there he says again
yesterday they're going to bring this
forward in terms of some of the answer
Trade union legislation look unions are
a Force for good we're not there with
some big red button in in general
secretary's offices that we press and
say everybody go out on strike that's
not how it works how strikes work is
there are people in workplaces who have
issues they are trying trying to get
them solved their employer says no and
then you see that their employer is
earning Millions if not billions of
pounds in profit not all employers but
some employers billions if not and
billions of pounds in profit and they're
saying to those workers take a pay cut
and so this government I think AIDS and
a bets that I think Jeremy Hunt will do
exactly the same and people be warned we
will be watching them carefully those
comments he made yesterday are is about
austerity they'll call it a different
word but what they mean is the pain yet
again will be taken by ordinary working
people and our communities uh now you
were saying there that strikes don't
work by unions pressing a big red button
and getting everyone to go on strike and
which of course I acknowledge
um I'm interested though in talk of
coordinated strike action now I've
spoken to the rmt in unison recently
Lynch said well we talk to each other it
will be silly for unions not to
coordinate their forces Christina McAfee
said well we're certainly getting close
to a coordinated strike are we getting
close to a coordinator strike well yes I
mean I've said uh yesterday that I think
there could be up to a million people on
strike um very very soon I mean what
we're seeing and I think we just have to
take this back as to why people go on
strike is that they can put all the
anti-trade union legislation in they
want they can pretend that it's Union
Barons pressing big red buttons this is
about anger anger in workplaces within
the public sector and in the private
sector so of course if I have the same
decision maker an employer that's the
same decision maker where members are in
another Union also of course we will
come together and we'll talk about how
we can get the best pay for workers this
is about winning money back into workers
Pockets so unite has had 450 disputes in
less than a year we've won over 200
million pounds back in to those workers
pockets and I unashamedly will do
everything I can to fight for workers
because they need someone in their
corner
when is a coordination Striker general
strike well on their space it's just
depending on words I mean for me this is
about issues that happen in a workplace
um those workers are trying to get
themselves nobody wants to have a strike
or nobody wants to have a general strike
but you've got to see that this is pure
anger that's happening and if there are
a number of strikes happening at the
same time people can call it what they
like quite frankly my job is to win for
those workers so if there are issues
where employers have unfettered profits
they are not giving some of that back to
the workers they're not getting their
piece of the pie then unions will do
everything in our power to make sure
that we get those workers a good deal so
we could be seeing General Stripes this
winter well you could see multiple
strikes this winter but what people call
it is really up to them but there will
be multiple strikes I know in my own
Millions there's been 450 strikes in
less than a year 90 000 unite members
have been out on strike 200 million
pounds have been won back in the pockets
of those workers that is the job of
trade Unions that's what we should be
doing and that's what we're doing more
and more of so I can see that that will
escalate the thing is to solve these
strikes so safely it's not about strikes
for strike's sakes the government needs
to look at how are they going to stop
saying that this country should take a
national paper that's what they're
saying it's almost like an abhorrence
now to ask for a pay rise that they
shouldn't be saying we should take a
national pay cut and allow us to get on
with our jobs stop trying to stop us and
let's get more money in people's pockets
um just finally
um you of course are the leading Union
in the health sector lots of people will
be quite concerned about the idea of
doctors and nurses going on strike and
the impact that could have on patients
and Healthcare
um are we looking at a strike in the NHS
is that going to happen do you think
well look I think we are looking at this
being a very um real option that is now
being looked at um it's not saying it's
taken lightly and but I do think I feel
quite embarrassed actually that we are
in a situation in our country where
these people went out and I know it said
a lot about these workers going out in
the pandemic and it's almost become
white noise but it's absolutely true
we've forgotten what happened there they
went out when everybody else was in
their homes all these key workers
whether it's the NHS or public sector
workers across the board and they took
risks they didn't know what was out
there they've come back and told you're
going to take a pay cut at the same time
they've told Bankers you can have a pay
rise there is something drastically
wrong with our economy if we allow that
to happen Okay thank you very much
fascinated to talk and thank you for
coming to the studio today thank you
very much
well a new Chancellor seemingly a whole
new economic approach in the treasury
Jeremy Hunt says there will now be some
tax Rises and also spending will have to
be looked at too so will it be enough to
calm the markets and just how much
economic damage has been done in the
last few weeks where we're joined now by
the former deputy governor of the bank
of England and a former member of the
office of budget responsibility Sir
Charles Bean thank you so much for being
with us it's it's good to have you here
um I just want to talk at the beginning
if I may about the interest rate
decision and because I think that's
going to be something that so many of
our viewers are going to be really
concerned about and we had the comments
of course from the governor of the bank
of England warning us to expect to hire
interest rate Rise um next month what
should we be bracing ourselves to say I
think there's actually been a bit of
misreporting of what Andrew said in
Washington uh yesterday because he was
talking about
um the interest rate decision relative
to what they were expecting back in
August when they did their last monetary
policy report so he wasn't saying
interest rates are going to have to rise
even more than we thought last week
uh really he was just reflecting the
fact that uh the pressures on interest
rates have risen in the past couple of
months reasons we all know uh what's
been happening in Ukraine and the mini
budget and he was merely saying to his
audience that they would they would need
to be raising Bank rates so I don't
think people should read anything from
that into their mortgage rates or
anything
uh what is an issue for their mortgage
rates is really what's happening to
Market interest rates they've already
moved up in anticipation of the bank's
future decisions and also reflecting the
turmoil in bond markets which followed
the mini budget the other week I mean
you're talking about the term on the
markets following the mini budget I mean
whenever I have government ministers you
know here in the studio they they try
and really talk about the global forces
which you acknowledge too you know in
Ukraine and the energy prices but it is
correct to say that a lot of this
turmoil is directly caused by the
government policy that we've seen uh yes
I I frankly I think it's disingenuous to
say it's all a global phenomenon it's
not there is a global element if you
look at the general level of interest
rates they've risen by about three
percentage points since the beginning of
the year
um
three quarters of that two-thirds maybe
is the world and what's happening in the
Ukraine but the rest of it is a UK
specific phenomenon and it's
particularly developed since the mini
budget so it's clearly driven by that in
my view and basically we've we've moved
from looking not too dissimilar from the
US or Germany as a a proposition to lend
to to looking more like Italy and Greece
right well that's a little doesn't it
really um what did you um make of the
new Chancellor's comments uh yesterday
do you think they would have gone some
way to implicating the market well I I
thought he set the right tone uh and
importantly he recognized that there are
some difficult decisions ahead he was
going to have to make pretty quickly I
have to say in the next couple of weeks
on both taxes and spending and the
important thing to realize is not simply
just a case of uh changing the identity
of the Chancellor or praying forward the
office budget responsibilities report
it's actually the contents and how the
numbers add up
and even before the mini budget in the
medium term there would have been a hole
in the public finances of 30 billion or
so to which the government layered on
another 45 subsequently reduced to
43 billion now they've done a u-turn on
little less than 20 billion of that so
there's still 40 billion they've got to
find from somewhere that's very chunky
so that's why he's right to say there's
some very difficult decisions and The
crucial thing will be whatever
is published in a couple of weeks time
on October the 31st is coherent and that
the market see there is a viable and
plausible plan for making everything fit
together I always feel and that you know
in these kind of political shows you end
up throwing around numbers 40 billion
and it's quite hard to realize what the
enormity of what we're talking about I
mean 40 billion pounds can you put it in
any context kind of you know squeeze
that we'd have to see to fill that Gap
okay well 40 billion is about uh two
percent of annual production of uh the
UK
um I cut in income tax of one percentage
point which is one of the things that
was in the mini budget bringing that
forward one year that costs about five
billion so 40 billion is is quite a lot
if you want to think about it in terms
of uh government spending uh you're
getting on for uh five or six percent
Cuts in government spending and it
should be said uh obviously the
government talking about you know
efficiency savings and stuff like that
the existing cash limits were set a year
ago when inflation was expected to stay
low uh pay increases in the public
sector were expected to be two or three
percent which is not sustainable now pay
in the private sector is growing at
about seven percent
um so already there is a big squeeze in
real terms on public spending and if
you're going to allow [ __ ]
that has to mean real Cuts you can't
find it from eliminating waste which
will no doubt be the um the Mantra but
there would have to be serious decisions
about things to uh to stop doing serious
decisions including potentially about
the NHS I was interested to read your
comments about you know if you wanted to
get the share of government spendings
GDP down you have to be prepared say to
move away from our own Health Service
free at the point of delivery to one
funded by social insurance yeah I hope
that again slightly mischievous
reporting this is part of a long
interview with your economics
correspondent Ed Conway how to take it
out with him uh well but but but the
essence of the point that I was making
is that actually the share of government
spending in GDP hasn't changed very much
over 50 years but beneath the surface
there's some very big trends and in
particular the share of health and
spending on uh welfare has risen from
about a quarter of that to half of that
and that larger affects demographics we
have an older population
uh and we've also decided to pay them
better pensions that's going to continue
in the future in the past that was
accommodated by Falling defense spending
falling debt interest spending falling
public capital investment all three of
those elements are programmed to go in
the other way now so it's a challenge
even to hold share of government
spending
constantly make Cuts but to make cuts
and the point that I wanted to stress is
you have to decide actually we want to
do things differently you can't achieve
these things simply by finding a billion
here a billion there
um
I think we are
in in terms of the
um indicators the economy is pretty much
flat lightning to slightly Contracting
looking forward I think it's pretty
inevitable that there will need to be a
period of uh of contraction how big we
don't know
uh but in some sense there needs to be
because the labor market is very tight
vacancies are still at a very high level
and that reflects the fact that half a
million people left the workforce as a
result of the pandemic and if we see a
squeeze in public spending in the fiscal
tightening could that make the recession
more difficult longer
well if you have a title fiscal position
that tends to mean lower demand lower
output but there's an offset to that
because the bank of England can then run
a looser monetary policy so it's the
flip side what we saw with the mini
budget so the mini budget was basically
something that was going to expand him
on
but in order for the bank of England to
meet its inflation Target it had to
offset the consequences of that by uh
prospectively raising bank rate more uh
so you can change the mix but the
overall level of demand has to be
consistent with the economy's supply
capacity
um just finally we'll have Andrew
Griffith on the show a little later uh
he is one of the few people to have
survived in the Treasury under quasi
Quantum and also the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt what would you ask him what
would you like to find out
well I would like to find out what their
plan is for essentially like making the
numbers add up in the medium term so
given that they want to have the ratio
of debt to GDP falling
four or five years out presumably uh
what is the balance they're going to
strike between raising taxes or cutting
government spending and if the latter
uh how they were expecting to achieve it
yeah that is the big question uh indeed
thank you so much you're very welcome uh
pleasure typing on the program
let's try and find out some of the
answers uh shall we to the question that
said you have been wanted to put the new
chancellor has adopted a very different
tone and indeed what seems to be a
pretty different economic approach since
taking the job on Friday Jeremy Hunt
says some taxes may have to rise and he
also indicated uh looking at a further
squeeze in public spending well Andrew
Griffith is the financial secretary to
the treasury he kept his job he joined
us now thank you for being with us I was
a bit worried we wouldn't actually make
it to the studio you tweeted I think a
picture of some cows are blocking your
path on the way in and always move on
good good to have you with us today
um firstly is Liz trust safe as prime
minister
it's just got the support of the
government it's really important that
this time that we have stability that's
what the chancellor has been talking
about that's what we're focused on in
government and that's why I think your
viewers at home expect of us you know
they're worried about their mortgages
they're worried about their energy costs
uh the last thing they want is more
politicians talking about themselves and
say to colleagues we've got to get
behind the Prime Minister work with the
new Chancellor put in place the right
medium-term financial plan that we need
and then move from there at the very
beginning of the program we to Robert
Halford who was pretty clear he was
worried he said talking to his
constituents who were frightened about
what was happening to the economy he
said that the current government looked
like you were blowing up not only the
conservative party but the country and
he effectively said that Liz truss has
got days to set out a new approach and
to convince his colleagues and also the
country that you've got a grip do you
accept that yeah my constituents is
worried too who who wouldn't be I mean
we've got a war on European soil uh
people have seen the turmoil in the
markets and that's why the prime
ministers acted and of course it's right
that the government looks like and is
focusing on on what really matters to
people stability the energy price
guarantee that we don't talk enough
about because it's a really big
intervention it's bigger than the
furlough I mean this affects every
single household every business for this
winter it's got a cost of around 100
billion which is one of the reasons why
we're having these conversations in such
a profound way but you've got to control
what you can control and what I and
other ministers can now do is work
really diligently night and day for the
next two weeks bring forward the plan
that will give us the stability and
confidence that we all need so did you
get it wrong then you know you announced
as you said this big spending energy
policy 100 billion pounds at the same
time as tax cuts at the same time that
you were saying you're going to be
sticking to the same extending envelope
was that wrong yeah for sure there's
things that I think everybody in
government would regret over the last
week and that's why the prime ministers
made changes but what we didn't get
wrong and remember that's where we had
to act when we did a head of energy
prices going up on the 1st of October
was that energy price guarantee that's
that's why the the growth plan came
forward when it did and what's not wrong
is to focus on economic growth you can't
just tax or spend your way to growth so
the prime minister's always been right
about the focus on economic growth going
forward so you're right on the energy
price guarantee you're right on the
focus on growth what were you wrong
about well the rate of which you could
proceed seed and as the chancellor said
yesterday not involved in the OVR in
those conversations I think it was it
was well meant to act as quickly as
possible uh but clearly that that has
caused some of the turbulence most of
that is due to global factors I agree
with your previous guest uh Charlie Bean
about three quarters of all of the
movements can be explained uh by global
factors but but that was wrong we fixed
that now and there's a real job of work
over the next few days and weeks not
long to wait
um about how we can lay out a budget and
give people the certainty and confidence
they need why was quasi quaten's Act
well as I say the Prime Minister
um concluded that the right thing to do
was to make a change it's not it's not
what anyone wants uh when people in
Westminster are talking about
Westminster Sophie I've got constituents
like Robert yeah people up and down the
country are worried come on who the
chancellor is and the reasons that the
chancellor was sacked after you know a
month in the job that is all about
policy people can be looking at the
Judgment of the Prime Minister and
thinking what on Earth is going on here
and the prime minister's exercised that
judgment she's brought in a new and
really experienced um Chancellor someone
um that's got a business background uh
that understands uh how you grow an
economy uh he set out some of his
priorities but but now we need a little
bit of time to do that work no one wants
those decisions to be rushed I
understand everyone wants uh decisions
about what's going to happen immediately
but we also want them to be right and we
want the obr to have a proper chance
um as we said that was something that
did that didn't go well
um we want to give the obr proper chance
to look at those figures and I want to
look at a bit more about what you like
to do in a moment but first just to look
at the resignation say a resignation
letter it wasn't really a resignation
was it the letter from quasi-quarting in
response to his sacking and I just
pulled out a couple of things here your
vision of this is to the Prime Minister
your vision of optimism growth and
change was right I believe your vision
is the right one we have responded to
those those events since we set out the
growth plan I mean it's pretty clear
looking at this letter from the
chancellor that he thinks that this was
the prime minister's Vision that he was
enacting and you can see why can't you
they were in lockstep together
and um we've all we're all in agreement
actually on the fundamental challenges
that we face which is this country needs
a greater rate of Top Line growth we
need to improve some of the workings of
government that just make everything
everything so slow Sophie it takes too
long to get the infrastructure built
it's too hard to get affordable child
care
um there's broad agreement around that
now any government is is a combination
of people working together trying to do
their best uh not always getting
everything right and it's up to the
prime minister to make those judgments
about how best to configure her team but
if everyone as you say you know you
agreed on on the strategy uh and quasi
quarantine thinks that he was enacting
the vision of the Prime Minister why was
he sacked was he sex his prime minister
who should be going in that case isn't
it no look this is a time when we need
stability I don't think anybody would
say that
um what the the country needs right now
is either more change inside the
Westminster bubble nor a labor
government that will actually come
forward and give more rights to the
Striking workers that are a real break
on people's ability to go to work
nationalizing energy companies or as
mayor Khan says taking us back into
Europe all of those things would
increase the level of uncertainty and
people at home are just tearing their
hair out with that level of uncertainty
what they want to see is competent
government getting on with the job and
that's and that's what that's what
exactly what we're going to do although
if you look at the polls what people at
home want to see is the labor government
well I I think what they actually want
to see that's a reaction to uh what's
been going on over the last couple of
weeks what they actually want is calm
they want stability and they want
confidence that's what the economy needs
as well okay um I just want to play you
a clip from the US president we've seen
it this morning I'm sure we've already
seen it but just for people at home this
is some comments from Joe Biden in an
ice cream parlor in Oregon let's just
listen to what you had to say and then
get your reaction
yeah
but look
um I'm just going to stop that for a
minute uh because that is clearly not a
picture of Joe Biden apologies it's not
and I'm not sure I knew I'm not sure
I've heard what he said anyway but can
we play let me just find out if we can
play
he was talking about the uh Liz truss
plan and he was overheard in an ice
cream parlor in Oregon saying well it
was predictable I wasn't the only one
who thought it was a mistake
I mean he is clearly talking about some
of the government strategy there
well as I say I didn't actually hear
that we didn't have the chance to uh to
see it on VT either
um the IMF who haven't been the the
biggest supporter of this government
actually did say that economic growth is
the right thing it's what every country
uh should be focusing on uh and I think
that's very hard to disagree with that
the government spends uh literally
hundreds of billions of pounds a year of
people's money
um there's always scope for that to be
improved and the UK economy hasn't grown
at the sort of rate that will give us a
sustainable NHS sustainable high quality
Public Services now an increase in
defense spend the only way of squaring
that Circle if you're not just gonna tax
hard-working people more which is not
the conservative way is to get the
economy to grow a bit faster I'm going
to try one more time to play the clip
because I appreciate it's difficult to
respond if you haven't heard let's have
a listen
well it's predictable I mean it was I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake yeah
but look she uh
but I think that uh
the idea
cutting taxes on the super wealthy at a
time when
anyway I just did I I disagreed with the
policy but that's up to Great Britain to
make that judgment not only
it's talking about cutting taxes some
ice cream he's got this yeah it's a
healthy ice cream and what do you make
of that though I mean you were as you
say you were in the treasury at the time
these decisions were being made cutting
taxes were super wealthy at a time for
economic growth the message that sends
out is so damaging and and that message
has changed but
Sophie 98 of that package which I regret
the fact
um that we've not talked enough about
that was the nion 100 billion a year
intervention to help to help families
you've already spoke about the energy
people package uh Robert Half an uh
earlier asked Liz trust to apologize to
his constituents you've admitted some of
your constituents were frightened you've
talked about soaring mortgage rates I
just don't understand why you don't just
come out and say look I'm really sorry
we got that badly wrong well effectively
I have I mean you can put different
words in my mouth but effectively
effectively I've said that but what I've
also said will you apologize then to
people who are seeing the mortgage rates
arises that we're looking at
the mortgage rates in the UK are very
similar to the mortgage rates in the US
and last time I looked we don't run the
U.S policy so this is something that is
happening globally I of course I regret
the fact that mortgage rates are rising
for anybody that's that's a really
challenging thing and what the
government's going to try and do both
through its intervention in energy I
know people don't want to talk about
that but that is that is the vast the
vast amount of the decisions that the
government have made is that energy
price guarantee that's giving people
confidence and certainty it's why
frankly some of the other elements of
that package which became a distraction
uh we had to move on from because it is
really important that people understand
that it also reduces the rate of
inflation so forecasters say that that
will reduce the rate of inflation which
is one of the headwinds that people are
facing on the cost of living by about
five percent now that's really valuable
Joe Biden is not doing that in the
United States we are doing that because
we're a compassionate conservative
government that's trying to protect the
most vulnerable people
so you're not taking the opportunity to
apologize I've I think I've been at
quite length though for you to talk
about things that we would do
differently but I'm much more interested
and I think your viewers are much more
interested in what happens now okay
going going to thank you for the
interview tips let's let's talk about
that now uh because uh the last
Wednesday at Prime Minister's questions
the Prime Minister was asked if she was
sticking to her promise that she was not
planning public spending reductions and
she replied absolutely Jeremy Hunt
yesterday said we're going to have to
look at some very tough decisions on
both suspending and tax all government
departments going to have to find more
efficiencies than they were planning to
so what is actually going on with
spending well I think spending will
continue to increase but perhaps not at
the same rate that it would have done
that's always an element of a of a four
so just to jump in there and Johnson
said there'll be difficult decisions
that need to be made again that's that's
fundamental I think we all understand
whether it's doing our household
economics or doing those for the country
that when you try and put a budget
together you do have to make some
difficult decisions so just just you
said that spending will continue to rise
but not as fast as some were expecting
previously the government was said it
was still committed to the current
spending envelope from the comprehensive
spending review is that still the case
the chance has been very clear that
everything's in scope and I think I
think Sophie that's the right thing to
do so that's not necessarily true
anymore that you were committed to that
spending envelope everything everything
is in scope those are the decisions for
the Prime Minister and the chancellor to
make once they've seen where the
opportunities are the state spends 900
billion pounds a year so whilst it's
really important it's vital that the
government puts fiscal in fiscal
Prudence at the heart of its budget and
that's what is going to happen over the
next few weeks with the support of the
obr it's never true that there are no
decisions that can be made within that
sort of envelope can you commit to the
proposed three percent increase in
defense spending well inimical to the
fact I'm saying that everything is in
scope there are no commitments I'm
afraid that I can make um nine o'clock
on a Sunday morning because we're going
into a process I think In fairness you'd
be the first to say look why would you
be making decisions uh without taking
those into full consideration and
without of course involving the obr
which is something that I think all of
us have said that with hindsight would
have been nicer to to do now listening
to Jeremy Hunt yesterday it sounds a lot
like you know trust anal mix is dead
he's talking about the need for fiscal
responsibilities spending restraints tax
Rises if necessary
he's really in charge here well he also
said that he is at one with the Prime
Minister on the big task facing our
country which is if we want to have high
quality Public Services we want to spend
more on the NHS we want to deal with
some of the really big issues in society
like decarbonization and have low taxes
that's going to make our economy
competitive then we're going to have to
have higher rate of economic growth his
words my words different ways of getting
there and that everyone wants growth
well it's the same it's the same
destination there'll always be I don't
think you'd see any government of any
stripe who said that they're not they
don't want economic growth the question
is how you get there and I have to say
Liz trust during that leadership
campaign Jeremy Hunt yesterday they have
got completely different Visions even
you would acknowledge that who is the
real prime minister Jeremy Hunt or will
this trust I I wholly disagree that they
have different visions and in fact I
think what unites the conservative party
is that we believe in a competitive
economy we believe in people keeping as
much of their own uh income as they can
we believe in low taxes but we also
believe in protecting the most fun
vulnerable and having high quality
public services so if we believe in all
of those things the only thing left to
reconcile is economic growth and we are
the party that wants to come forward we
want to improve the clock speed of the
economy these things they call supply
side measures are really real because
they are you know getting that local
Road built making sure there's a new
facility for your local GP those are the
sort of things my constituents are
worried about um just finally and I know
you want to talk about policies rather
than personalities but the papers are
full of speculation about potential
Unity candidates to replace Liz truss
quite an unusual one on the front page
of the Sunday mail I'm not sure if
you've seen it but the front page of the
Sunday mail showed a picture of yourself
uh saying that you might be able to
about to enter number 10. I can give you
an exclusive that that is absolutely
never going to happen Sophie I think
poor old thing I think poor old Ben
Wallace has been greatly greatly
slandered if whatever the term is but no
a very important job to do supporting
the chancellor on a serious note what
would you say to colleagues who were
looking uh to put Liz trusts on notice
who are looking and having those
conversations trying to find a Unity
candidate they're worried about the
polls they're worried about the economy
and they think it's time for her to go
I understand the worry of of colleagues
they're all trying to do the best for
their constituents but if we want to be
taken seriously as a party seriously in
the country we have to unite we have to
get behind the Prime Minister you know
Europe there is a war on European soil
people are facing a really difficult
cost of living Challenge and they're
really worried and so they don't want to
hear disunity from the conservative
party they don't want to hear about
another leadership campaign we saw the
damage frankly that that did this summer
they want us to unite be serious and get
back to work and do what we've got to do
over the next couple of weeks okay thank
you very much for being on the program
uh today thank you well let's go
straight to Labor's Jonathan Reynolds
now at shall we who joins us from
Central London uh we just heard there
from the government saying that the
chancellor and the new prime minister
are at one with their vision for the
country do you agree
no I don't and I think the last three
weeks have been quite frankly a disgrace
and an embarrassment to anyone who cares
about this country and the people who
live here I mean look the damage has
been done already you know whatever
moves we see from the conservative party
whoever gets a chance of being
Chancellor this month or whoever frankly
is prime minister by next week people's
mortgages are higher than they needed to
be business investment will be lower
than it otherwise would have been and
government expenditure and the pressures
on that will be worse because of
decisions that were made and I think
every time conservative ministers come
on and pretend that somehow this isn't
their responsibility confidence only
diminishes in them still further and
there are real world consequences to
that
I just want to talk to you about the
interview that we did at the beginning
of the program with Rob Halford and the
chair of the education select committee
he accused the government of blowing up
the party and the country and said that
Liz truss's government was treating the
country's laboratory mice to carry out
ultra-free Market experiments
Labor's position on the number of
conservative MPS who are clearly
concerned about the direction of the
government and are you having
conversations with them
look we're always open for conversations
but quite frankly what this country
needs is is not conversations in
Westminster it needs a general election
where the public will get there say on
the future of government policy rather
than being decided anywhere else I mean
let's just look at you know who is in
charge of this government what are this
government's policies what which bits of
the budget still apply I genuinely don't
know the answers to those questions and
frankly what is required is fresh ideas
I think that requires a labor government
and I don't see how the conservative
party keeps believing it can change
Chancellor or even leader without the
public having their say
um I just want to talk about reports in
the paper that delaying that the
government's now considering delaying
the Wimpy cut in income tax now that
would of course mean that in some ways
labor further to the right than the
conservatives on tax because you said
that you'd back the 1p cut to income tax
in April next year is that still your
position or are you changing with the
government
well our position has always been that
personal taxes in the UK are high
because growth has been so low so dismal
for the last 12 years so we've been
completely consistent in endorsing that
change now clearly what I need to know
what we all need to know is what the
state of the national finances really
are after this incredible damage that
the conservative party has done to them
so I need the obr forecast in order to
make any kind of assessment around that
I think that's the only reasonable
position to take but we are confident
that we could have a higher level of
economic growth than the conservative
body because our policies are not based
on you know this misplaced sense of
trickle down by cutting taxes for people
at the top hours are based on long-term
business investment and long-term
industrial strategy but clearly so I
need to know what the real picture is we
all need that before we can make any
further decisions and to be frank we
don't know which bits of the budget
still apply or not this morning
do you think that some people are
listening to you might be a little bit
concerned though you know you're saying
they're about look don't worry uh our
growth will be higher than the
conservatives growth after what's
happened over the last month uh with you
know the argument that look you perhaps
don't need the same fiscal constraints
because growth will be high don't you
think people will think oh yeah I've
heard this one before higher growth that
means we don't have to be as responsible
with the finances and just won't buy it
it's not about being irresponsible with
the finances I mean first of all I would
say look the key problem in the British
economy is that business investment is
the lowest in the G7 and because of what
the conservative party has done might
even be near the bottom of the G20 so
long-term industrial strategy is a real
way to drive that up reforming business
rates improving our trading relationship
with the European Union improving skills
these are all real things but we've also
been absolutely clear that what
dominates for us what the overriding
rule is as Rachel Reeves has set out is
fiscal responsibility and that means we
will not borrow for day-to-day spending
we don't believe as the conservatives do
you can borrow money to pay for tax cuts
for the well-off and somehow that will
make everything better we're absolutely
clear on that and that will always apply
and will make decisions once we have
seen the obr forecasts but there is no
doubt for us fiscal responsibility rules
and I think that's been endorsed
entirely frankly with what we've seen in
the last three weeks
let's talk about fiscal responsibility
shall we because what I was very
interested to hear from Andrew Griffith
was that we've previously been told that
this government is going to be sticking
to the current spending envelopes that
is now not necessarily uh true he says
all things are on the table so that does
potentially mean spending not Rising as
fast as we were expecting would a labor
government spend more than the
conservatives on public services
but we would only spend more on
day-to-day Public Services where we can
identify additional Revenue that would
pay for that so for instance abolishing
the non-dumbreal brings in over three
billion pounds we would tax private
Equity income differently to how the
conservatives do it so we're absolutely
clear on that I do want to say however
any spending cuts the conservative party
brings forward are entirely of its own
making I mean Liz trust did give a
commitment in prime minister's questions
on Wednesday which said absolutely there
would be no spending costs but anything
they bring forward will be solely on
them and their incompetence and quite
frankly looking at the state of the NHS
the criminal justice system Law and
Order in this country I don't see where
they're going to get a lot of this money
that they're hinting at so look I'll
spending envelope would be different
because we can identify additional
Revenue that we would bring in and
frankly we'd borrow less money because
our windfall tax would be more extensive
than the conservative one so we're clear
on on that bid but if the conservatives
think they can do austerity again the
state they've left the country in after
12 years I think they really need to
think quite seriously about where
they'll get that money from
does that mean that tax will go up under
labor
no it doesn't mean the tax will go up it
means additional sources of of Revenue
as I say like abolishing the non-dom
rule or the charitable status of private
schools being reviewed or other changes
how private Equity is taxed we will
always identify where Revenue will come
from where we will increase day-to-day
spending but look anyone who doubts that
approach look at what happens when you
have a government that isn't committed
to that kind of fiscal responsibility it
means you're paying more on your
mortgage it means your workplace your
employer your business can't invest as
it wants to do it means the government
is paying more in the debt interest or
on the national debt so that there are
real world consequences to the kind of
irresponsibility we've seen from the
conservative party I just want to I just
want to come in labor party has
committed to that I just want to come in
because you know I'm no Economist but
for me these numbers are just nowhere
near adding up so you know we spoke to
Charlie Bean at the former official from
the bank of England he said there's a 14
billion pound black hole that needs to
be plugged in the things that you're
talking about you know private schools
can't be Charities 1.7 billion pounds
but that's not going to touch the sides
does it
well look I I can only make those
decisions based on real information from
the obr and other forecasts I can't do
it off of newspaper speculation I mean
there are there are stories that have
been placed overnight by the government
or people leaking from it about
potentially very large sums of money but
that is the consequence of incompetence
so I need I need that information before
we can make further decisions about that
but being no doubt that for us our
fiscal rules and fiscal responsibility
will always govern any of the decisions
that we make okay thank you very much uh
Jonathan Reynolds out there from labor
thank you
uh well that is it for this week's
safety Ridge on Sunday pretty clear the
disgruntlement in the conservative
Ventures days to turn it around
according to Robert Half and looks like
it's going to be another busy week ahead
well in a moment we'll be running
through today's interviews having a look
at what we learned we'll be joined by
our Deputy political editor at Sam
Coates where Paul will also be here with
us thank you for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
hello welcome to Sophie Roger on Sunday
the take now we're going to discuss some
of the interviews that we've heard on
today's show try to work out what we've
learned with the help of our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates we're also
joined by political correspondent Rob
Powell but just firstly I just wanted to
take a moment to reflect on what an
extraordinary week it's been and we've
got a new Chancellor we've got a new
strategy a new policy and things are
really moving at breathtaking at speed
and I did feel that some of the
interviews on the show really reflected
that firstly of course with Rob Halford
who had some pretty clear words for the
government saying that they were
treating the public as laboratory rats
but also with City Minister Andrew
Griffith who effectively said the
current spending plans are potentially
on the ropes that they could be looked
at again very different to what we've
heard from him previously well let's
bring in Rob power shall we first who's
in the studio with us Rob lovely to have
you on the take good to see you uh what
is your I mean I just I thought the
powerful interview was kind of
extraordinary talking about just days to
turn it around what is your take on
whether Liz truss has done enough to
shore up her position not at the moment
I don't think I think when you talk to
MPS and what's interesting about the Rob
Halford interview today was it was
almost a public on-camera articulation
of what you usually get sort of behind
closed doors in Anonymous briefings that
pop up in newspapers plenty of which
there is in the papers
um this morning I think the difficulty
is is that listening to her new
Chancellor yesterday doing interviews
you could be in no doubt that the
central vision of trussonomics the Liz
truss economic agenda that she spent the
summer outlining and won her place in
down the street on the back of has gone
completely in the bin now he talked
about some taxes Rising tax cuts not
happening as fast as many might like and
that's why Andrew Griffith had a really
difficult job this morning because he's
one of the treasury ministers that has
been there through this massive change
engine approach in the treasury he's
been imposed in that department and
what's more he was one of the people
sent out when this turmoil in the
markets first started to kick off to
defend the government's approach and he
is now out defending essentially this
big uh change and I think when you take
what what Jeremy Hunt talked about
yesterday and compare it to Liz truss's
piece in the sun on Sunday this morning
which is very business as usual talking
about her priority for growth about how
she's not giving up on her Central
Mission about how this is only just the
beginning it's so hard to square those
two and so when Andrew Griffith says
that the PM and a Chancellor are sharing
the same vision that's very hard to
believe yeah I was trying to sort of get
to the point as well about you know who
is who's got the real power here it's
easier to see a way of Liz trust losing
her job you know particularly if you
listen to people like Rob Halford who's
admit very very openly that yet these
conversations are happening they are
happening right now as we speak and
Jeremy Hunt who actually seems I mean to
lose one Chancellor after such a short
period uh is is it's in clear unclear
she can even get away with that let
alone too he seems very secure in his
job I mean who where is the real power
yeah there's an argument here that
Jeremy Hunt is almost a sort of
caretaker prime minister in all but name
already he said yesterday that he got
permission to Tinker around with
whatever bits of the mini budget he
wants Andrew Griffith there said that
everything is within Scopes that's why
we're looking at potentially the basic
rate of tax being
um pushed back after it was accelerated
um by this trust and I think that is why
lots of Tory MP are asking themselves if
the primary purpose of this government
now is to sort of repair the damage that
it's done to itself over the last three
or four weeks then what is the point of
Liz truss being prime minister if none
of the things that she has been offering
are going to make it into policy and if
the sort of central ideological purpose
of this government is now completely
vanished really interesting to get your
opinion on that Rob this morning thank
you right let's talk let's look listen
to shall we to the interview that we
were just discussing with Rob the chair
of the education select committee
concerned for MP Robert Halford and I
have to say you know we thought that he
was going to be pretty explicit and I
was actually quite taken aback by just
how open he was on the program this
morning let's listen
well I worry that over the past few
weeks the government has looked like
libertarian jihadists and and treated
the whole country as a kind of
laboratory mice in which to carry out
kind of ultra ultra-free Market
experiments and this is not where the
where the country is there's been one
Horror Story a story after another well
at this time I'm not calling for the
prime minister to go I worry about
further political instability but even
more economic instability but things
have to improve
well let's bring in our Deputy political
editor Sam coats shall we uh Sam we
didn't hold back the governments looked
like libertarian jihadists and true to
the country like laboratory mice
yeah what I thought was interesting
about Robert Halford was not that he
wasn't yet calling for Liz trust to go
though it sounded quite frankly that he
was not not a million miles away from it
um but that there was no area of her
government that he seemed happy with uh
whether it was tone whether it was
approach and and for him it didn't feel
like simply the appointment of Jeremy
Hunt had really done anything to start
to stem the political bleeding really on
two fronts first of all what Rob Halford
made very clear is that he's incredibly
nervous and he's reflecting uh what he
says is the Fright of his constituents
over
um really over those spending cuts that
are now very much on the table when you
spoke to Andrew Griffith as he confirmed
that they were uh that's exactly what
they were changing and yet another
U-turn from a few days ago they weren't
going to stick to the spending plans
that were negotiated under Boris Johnson
for the next three years Rob Halford
made clear he's very very worried about
that and uh and so there's going to be a
very difficult three weeks as Tory MPS
find out which budgets that people rely
on are being slashed but also Rob
Halford made clear that he basically
disagreed with the one sing the one
thing that this government's Clinging On
to which is the energy support package
the 100 billion pound package that
Andrew Griffis
um was extremely enthusiastic to talk
about uh time and time and time again
but actually that senior Tory MP that
kicked off your show made clear he
wasn't happy with it because it was so
Universal it was so expensive it was
giving lots of help lots of expensive
help to big corporates and to richer
individuals and he was sort of basically
wondering why we're having to cut Public
Services uh to spend money on the energy
bills of massive corporations so the
government might think that they've got
one remaining argument that Jeremy hung
yesterday and Rob Halford today were
very very clear that they were going to
hammer home as they thought their
winning trump card but even amongst
jewelry MPS it ain't cutting it I want
to ask you a bit Sam about the time
frame as well and because look Rob
Halford is someone who doesn't just he's
not one of these kind of rent to quote
politicians I guess he will always just
come on and stick the beat in this is
the first intervention he's publicly
made we know that he spoke to his trusts
at the private meeting and so you'll
have thought about it and he'll have
chosen his words carefully and he was
talking about Liz truss having days to
prove to the party that something has
changed I mean how how tight is the time
frame
well look I I think most conservatives
if nothing else big happens in the
coming days this week and and by nothing
else big I sort of mean a catastrophe on
the financial Market but if nothing else
big happens this week then I think that
this government has has probably got
until October 31st now Halloween is the
date that Jeremy Hunt will now come
forward and set out with his plan to
calm the markets his plan to show how
borrowing uh is brought back under down
to uh kind of slightly more reasonable
levels how Britain can show that it's
going to end up spending less than it
borrows in what they call the medium
term which is a usually about a
five-year time Horizon
um and uh then everyone will take stock
and look again because the thing is that
Liz truss spent so much money in the
opening days of her Premiership we're
talking hundreds of billions of pounds
only some of that has been gone back on
I mean even this morning they're talking
about delaying the 1p income tax cut but
that's only delaying it by a year that
doesn't really deal with the debt
doesn't really deal potentially with the
deficit so there is still so much
additional money that they've got to
find by spending cuts so I think that
there just could be a mounting sense of
absolute Horror in the current three
weeks about the decisions that are going
to have to be made 40 billion pounds is
the amount that George Osborne announced
a additional amount he was going to cut
in 2010 so if you thought that austerity
1.0 that 2010 to 2015 uh phase was bad
then think of another 40 billion on top
of that after arguably all the fat has
been trimmed from the public service
from public services so this is going to
be a very very gruesome and grisly
exercise there are some accounting
tricks they can use like potentially
raising the state pension age or
increasing net migration which will feed
through into better growth forecasts and
lower borrowing figures but really there
isn't any way around it seems to me a
huge huge painful spending cuts all over
the public sector including public
sector pay freezes and pay squeezes of
the sort that Sharon Graham thinks is
going to trigger more strikes so this is
just such a difficult vision for Tori
MPS to get their head around just weeks
after Liz trust said that none of this
would happen
yeah it's extraordinary isn't it really
Robert Half and also called on listos to
apologize for the turmoil that we've
seen over the last few weeks so I did
put that to the treasury Minister Andrew
Griffith let's have a little listen to
him yeah my constituents is worried too
who who wouldn't be I mean we've got a
war on European soil uh people have seen
the turmoil in the markets and that's
why the prime ministers acted
um and of course it's right that the
government looks like and is focusing on
on what really matters to people
stability uh the energy price guarantee
that we don't talk enough about because
it's a really big intervention it's
bigger than the furlough I mean this
affects every single household every
business for this winter it's got a cost
of around 100 billion which is one of
the reasons why we're having these
conversations in such a profound way for
sure there's things that I think
everybody in government would regret
over the last week and that's why the
prime ministers made changes
uh let's bring in Sam again shall we Sam
what's your take on the interview with
Andrew Griffith it's a quite a difficult
position for him because of course he is
one of the people who's been in the
treasury right from the beginning
I mean this extraordinary argument he's
having to make he's traveling to both
say well it's all change and now it's
Steady As She Goes and everything's
going to be fine even though the person
who made the decisions that we've had to
junk is still in the top job I mean it's
not an easy sell of a position is it
um and he did it as smoothly and as
competently as you would expect but it's
just a very very tall order because this
government is breaking its own Promises
to the 80 000 until we members that
elected it left right and Center
um Jeremy Hunt is talking about having
to raise taxes
um and Liz trust stood on a platform
that the tax burden was too high and she
stood on on a platform that saw
corporation tax not rising and I think
that toys are having to swallow that
plus the impending spending cuts now
what was interesting I think was that
um there is this desperation to try and
blame other people uh I for weeks have
heard people try and blame the bank of
England we heard Jacob Reese smoke
blaming the bank of England on Thursday
I suspect with Jeremy Hunt in the
Chancellor's chair he's going to make it
absolutely clear that he's working
together with the bank of England rather
than rather than blaming him you you
heard what I very much thought was
Andrew Griffith's hold two simultaneous
positions he conceded that about a
quarter of the problem was domestic
three-quarters of the economic pain uh
the internal that we're seeing is due to
global factors one quarter he said was
because of domestic factors echoing what
Charlie Bean said
um but he also then said that mortgage
rates the great big political problem
that people are going to be facing over
the coming weeks and months uh is
actually uh our mortgage director on the
same level as those in the United States
I think some of that is going to require
some uh unpicking by analysts voters and
MPS in the coming in the coming days so
it's not an easy sell and you know what
didn't massively feature this morning
was a huge discussion of mortgages but
we are looking talking now at people
facing five thousand pounds a year
additional on their mortgage eight
thousand pounds additional uh on their
mortgage uh if they live in London with
uh interest rates at the end of 2026
settling the resolution Foundation thing
around about six percent where there was
zero nine months ago so the scale of the
sort of economic catastrophe
um uh that could well unfold I think is
uh is quite breathtaking so
um sort of political smoothing of uh uh
of the last few days yes it's necessary
any politician worth it should be able
to do it but dealing with the actual
challenges well that's just so much
harder
uh so much harder indeed as Sam always
good to talk on a Sunday morning uh
we'll be back with you and Rob as well
uh after a short break
welcome back to Sophie Richard on Sunday
at the tape we've got Rob pal here in
the studio for us and we've been talking
a lot about
um trough economics the future of Liz
trust let's talk about what the last
week means for policy because I felt
like one of the bigger lines from the
interviews today was the acknowledgments
from the treasury Minister Andrew
Griffith that actually the current
spending envelope no longer applies and
that is the first time I think there's
been an acknowledgment that that is
that's the comprehensive spending review
is now you know up the grams yeah and it
was going to be tight anyway because
that comprehensive spelling review was
set before you were getting almost
double-digit inflation so in real terms
it was going to be tight anyway and now
the treasury indicating that it's going
to be even tighter
um we also had sir Charlie Bean on today
now he's been warning for a few weeks
now that actually such is the black hole
that appears to be in the public
finances something will be needed in the
order of the austerity years of the
2010s to get this sort of on an even
Keel again he repeated that that message
today and how that plays out and what
that means politically it just has so
many political ramifications we've been
talking a lot about defense and whether
that three percent of GDP in the next
eight years defense Target is kept with
reports that Ben Wallace could even walk
if that's not met but you're seeing some
of the wrangling starting already with
Rob halffon the chair of the education
select committee saying well if you're
going to make these cast iron guarantees
for defense what about essential
Services
um like schools you obviously had Sharon
Graham from unite on as well what does
this mean for public sector pay and if
there aren't sufficient pay rises in the
eyes of the unions what's that mean for
strikes when it comes to nurses when it
comes for teachers as well so
a lot of political but also very
practical ramifications for the big
tough decisions that Jeremy Hunt and
this trust are going to have to make in
the coming weeks we mentioned uh Charlie
being there and I have to say the
interview that we did with him was one
that I think will stay with me I quite I
enjoy these interviews with people who
you know have held these really big
previous jobs Deputy Governor the bank
of England offers a budget
responsibility who no longer in them as
well because they do have the freedom to
explain what's really going on let's
have a listen he was quite dismissive of
suggestions that Global factors were
solely to blame for the recent economic
turmoil
frankly I think it's disingenuous to say
it's all the global phenomenon it's not
there is a global element if you look at
the general level of interest rates
they've risen by about three percentage
points since the beginning of the year
um
three quarters of that two-thirds maybe
is the world and what's happening in the
Ukraine but the rest of it is a UK
specific phenomenon and it's
particularly developed since the mini
budget so it's clearly driven by that in
my view and basically we've we've moved
from looking not too dissimilar from the
US or Germany as a a proposition to lend
to to looking more like Italy and Greece
well let's bring some coats back in
according to Charlie being there we've
gone from looking like the US and
Germany is a proposition to lend to to
Italy and Greece
and this is the problem facing all the
people who need to remortgage over the
next uh few years and interest rates
will stay high for for many many years
to come as we would just uh as as we
were just talking and it is that
contrast between the fact that this
government didn't think that it could
afford uh that the public could afford a
thousand pounds a month uh additional on
their energy bill is that a thousand
pounds a year additional on their energy
bills uh but now is facing five six
seven eight thousand pounds additional
on their mortgages uh what on Earth can
this government do to help uh homeowners
and of course it's not just homemade
there's people in rented a common
accommodation find that the amount of
money uh that they're having uh the
amount of their rent is going up because
the people who own the properties have
to pay more on there uh on their uh on
their properties as well so this is a
sort of almost insoluble problem and and
we haven't begun to hear from people uh
exactly how uh the government's going to
address it whether or not they're just
going to have to let it let it work
through part of it of course it is
global the reason that we've got high
mortgages is higher inflation which is
because of the war in Ukraine part of it
I think most economists like Charlie
been acknowledging that that's because
of the direct decisions of Liz truss's
government the great big challenge for
the labor party is to make sure that the
public understand uh or believe that
there's a direct link between what she
did and the amount that they're playing
on their on their mortgages
and that's going to be one of the great
big contests I think in the in the
coming weeks and months and years of of
British politics but there's quite a lot
of evidence out there to suggest that
there is something of a correlation
between those two things so this is this
this really goes to the very very heart
of British politics at the moment it's
fascinating isn't it and it does feel
doesn't it that we're really starting to
look at that Halloween date at the 31st
to see what the new Chancellor can come
up with to get the market confidence
back to please people like Charlie Bean
is talking about 40 billion pound uh
black hole but also to keep someone like
Robert Halford on site who is deeply
worried about spending cuts to Public
Services
that's right and and
um and ultimately Tory MPS might decide
that they can't really Square the circle
but the problems don't go away in a
funny way Jeremy Hunt came in we had our
fourth Chancellor in four months on
Friday and some big ticket items have
been Jay have been uh have been junked
but at the same time uh what isn't at
all clear is that any the change of
personnel change of approach really
solves the problems that this government
have got they remain whoever the prime
minister is whoever the chancellor is uh
just so so difficult
I'm always eager to talk and to get your
take on the current turmoil that we have
I've got a feeling that you're going to
have a busy couple of weeks coming up uh
that is it in the meantime for safer
Ridge on Sunday the take this morning
after another extraordinary few days uh
in politics we're on our fourth
Chancellor now in just four months we'll
be doing the podcasts they do check that
out available from around at lunchtime
with the best bits from our interviews
and also analysis former producer at
Scott Beasley we'll have a bit from
repel on that pod as well coming up and
on Wednesday we'll have Sunshine Sophie
Ridge on the take on Wednesday 9pm to
who knows where we're going to be by
then uh frankly I don't think that this
is something that's going to be resolved
in just a couple of days see you next
week
[Music]